Ashish this is a particular a type of
strep a isn't it invasive strep a um how
worried do parents need to be
parents need to be vigilant but not
unduly concerned Sam I've been talking
to Pediatric Consultants about strep
pain and this particular strappe
outbreak for the last couple of weeks
we're seeing more cases there is
definitely an uptick in cases that that
any pediatric consultant anywhere in the
country will tell you we are seeing what
might be considered more children dying
than you would normally see in a winter
but we haven't had this around for the
last couple of years because of the
pandemic and because of the restrictions
on movements the infection hasn't been
able to spread so strep a is a very
common bug that children and adults will
pick up most of the time nearly in all
cases you might have a sore throat or
present with the sort of symptoms that
you might have with a really bad cold or
a throat infection or tonsillitis
and you will recover from that but
certainly the the three tragedies that
we are aware of the one in uh Surrey the
one in Wales very recently and today the
tragic news of a child in West London as
well that tells us that there is a a a
higher amount of more dangerous cases
affecting children in a more dangerous
way but we mustn't be alarmist and we
mustn't be saying that there is a surge
in cases and that all children are going
to fall ill and some will become very
ill and will have to go to hospital and
ultimately some may die
that said it is important and public
health officials will say the same thing
that parents who will be worried
naturally you'll be worried about
protecting your own children should just
be vigilant of the signs and if they're
worried and if they think something is
affecting their child's health they
should contact their doctors and seek
medical advice this is what the public
health director an expert a consultant
in communicable diseases in public
health Wales told Sky earlier about the
signs that parents should be aware of
what we are asking the parents across
Wales in fact not just with the school
because just one case occurring doesn't
mean that there is a much more higher
risk to all the children in that school
but parents uh in the class that we have
contacted we're asking them to look for
if their child has got tonsillitis sore
throat and or high fever and or if they
might have any severe muscle ache or
redness if they do have these symptoms
then we're advising parents to contact
their doctor who may decide to prescribe
antibiotic
Dr Adriana Genie saying what most
doctors will be telling you that these
are treatable with antibiotics and if
parents suspect that their children have
these symptoms to seek medical advice